good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 89
object class euclid Cibolo special
containment procedures SCP 89 is stored
in a special shipping container at site
36 and monitored for locution events
mobile task force mu 89 consisting of
personnel with advanced training in
linguistics psychology and tactical
diplomacy has been established in order
to respond to such locution events upon
the occurrence of allocution event
mobile task force mu 89 is to translate
and interpret the locution so as to
identify the primary subjects of that
trigger here in designated as SCP 89 a
and SCP 89 B then execute protocol m 8
which consists of the following steps
number 1 transport SCP 89 - SCP 89 a's
location and explained protocol m8 - SCP
89 b and number 2 at such time as SCP 89
b is prepared to voluntarily execute
protocol m 8 render - SCP 89 be any
assistance as a CP 89 be may request in
connection with a CPA d9 be performing
the following actions inserting SCP 89 a
into the cavity together with
inflammable materials such as oiled wood
or charcoal then igniting them the
successful execution of protocol m 8
requires the voluntary compliance of SCP
89 be the sober and uncoerced state
likewise a CP 89 a must be conscious and
alert during the execution of the
protocol it is recommended that SCP 89
be be restrained although not sedated
following ignition so as to avoid
interference with the completion of the
protocol as the process is extremely
painful and fatal to SCP 89 a
if SCP 89b refuses to voluntarily
execute protocol m8 in accordance with
the after mentioned specifications
mobile task force mu 89 is to explain
the prospective consequences of failing
to successfully complete the protocol
and make every effort to persuade a CP
89 be to cooperate if mobile task force
mu 89 s best efforts do so persuade SCP
89 be are unsuccessful SCP 89 is to be
re-designated as Keter class and
protocol m 9 is to be executed reference
document 89 m 9 the use of intimidation
threats mind-altering drugs or
intoxicants in an effort to effect SCP
89 B's free will and any attempt to
complete protocol m 8 without SCP 89 B's
participation or voluntary cooperation
or otherwise other than described are
strictly prohibited since these measures
invalidate the attempted completion of
the protocol and are known to intensify
the severity of the attendant type s
event it is also recommended although
not a required part of protocol m 8 to
cause the execution of step 2 of
protocol m 8 to be accompanied by the
sounding of horns and percussion
instruments as doing so may mask the
sounds made by a CP 89 a during the
execution of the protocol upon a
successful execution of protocol m 8 the
related type s event generally begins to
abate within seven hours description SCP
89 is a glazed earthenware statue
approximately three meters in height
depicting a winged bull headed humanoid
with an open mouth the front of the
statues torso is hinged and can be
opened from the top to reveal a cavity
approximately 0.6 cubic meters in volume
and can be locked from the outside the
rear of the statue bears an inscription
in a
language possibly Punic the statute
dates from approximately the second
century BCE on infrequent occasions
sometimes separated by periods in excess
of a century the statue speaks the
mechanism by which these sounds are made
is not understood and the mouth of the
statue does not move the statues
locutions are in a canon i language
probably the same language as the
inscription and consists of the name or
a description of SCP 89a a demand for
protocol m8 to be accomplished together
with instructions for doing so and the
description of the attendant type s
event in a figurative language
each locution event is followed within a
period of 3 to 11 days by the
commencement of a type s event meeting
the description given in the locution
event unless protocol m8 has already
been completed each type s event is an
epidemic natural disaster mass hysteria
evolving genocide or other massacres or
other event involving extensive damage
to property and loss of human lives over
a period of time that continues until
protocol m8 is successfully completed in
the case of each documented locution
event the attendant type s event while
significant is limited to a geographic
area that does not directly affect SCP
89b
this has in some documented cases
resulted in the pendency of a type s
event for an extended duration of time
due to SCP 89 B's unawareness of SCP 89
of protocol m8 or 2 SCP 89 B's
unwillingness to undertake protocol m8
in order to arrest the type s event
for each locution event SCP 89a is a
healthy unblemished human infant or
child between eight months and six years
of age SCP 89b
is that child's natural mother in all
documented cases at the time of the
locution event SCP 89 a and b rh alive
and healthy and experience a strong bond
of trust and affection with each other
following SCP 89 bees placement of SCP
89 a in the cavity and the ignition of
the inflammable materials as CP 89 a
will burn and be destroyed over a period
of two to five hours
[Music]
addendum number 1 memo to file for dr.
Garcia while the role of SCP 89 in
actually causing type s events is
unclear experience is demonstrated that
the prompt and precise application of
protocol m8 is effective in limiting the
damage that they do dr. Patel has
speculated that SCP 89 does not cause
type s events but merely anticipates
them and provides a means to mitigate
their effects addendum to a partial list
of documented type s events that were
terminated by means of protocol m8
inclusive of documented completions of
protocol m8 that predate the
Foundation's acquisition of custody of a
CP 89 follows date of locution March
21st 1788 description of type s event in
locution event the flame shall consume
their houses yeah and their markets and
their temples and all of their dwelling
places they shall be destroyed type s
event fire in Cydia outcome protocol m8
completed day 29 after locution event
66% of cities buildings destroyed
date of locution December 2nd 1850
description of type s event in locution
event the false prophet shall gather the
multitude unto Him and cast them against
the princes they shall each of them be
slain and their fields made barren type
s event large-scale messianic base
peasant uprising and outcome protocol m8
completed day 1363 after locution event
massacre is associated with uprising and
its suppression and attendant
agricultural collapse account for at
least million casualties date of
locution November 23rd 1951 description
of type s event in locution event the
earth shall tremble and the seas shall
rise and be cast against the earth and
the mountain shall hamid fire its voice
shall be darkness and death
type s event earthquake and volcanic
eruption and outcome protocol m8
executed within 31 hours of allocution
event no tsunami resulted although
geological models had anticipated that
one would occur from a seismic event in
that area no fatalities date of locution
November 7th 1970 description of type s
event in locution event the rain shall
scour the earth and sweep away man and
his beasts and all his works the deluge
shall take them all type s event cyclone
and outcome Protocol m8 executed on day
49 after locution event casualties from
flooding disease and starvation
estimated at thousand date of locution
april 4th 2015 description of type s
event and locution event type s event
outcome ongoing protocol m8 not yet
executed
okay that about does it for today thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well as it patreon.com forward
slash the volcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]